in this video we'll see how to debug an
error you encounter when running
trainer.train
as an example we'll use this script that
fine tune the bird model on the glue
mnli dataset
check out the videos linked below to see
how we came to search a script
here we want to learn how to debug the
problems in it
running the script gives us an error
pretty quickly it happens at the line
where we feed the inputs to the model
according to the trades back
that tells us there's a problem there
but the problem could come from many
different causes
to debug an error in a training you need
to make sure each step of the training
pipeline works as intended this means
checking that the inputs of your data
sets are correct
you can batch them together feed them
through the model to get the loss then
compute the gradients of atlas before
performing an optimizer step
so let's start by looking at the
training data set this trainer is using
there's definitely a problem here
we see text and that number
the error message was telling us the
model did not get input ids and we do
not have those in the data set indeed
looking back at our code
we can see we made a mistake and passed
the wrong data sets to the trainer
so let's fix that and run again
now we have a new error inspecting the
traceback tells us it happens when we
try to create a batch specifically to
group the features in a tensor
we can confirm this by asking the
trainer to get us a batch of the
training data loader which reproduces
the same error
either by inspecting the inputs or
debugging we can then see they are not
all of the same size
this is because we have not passed a
data collector to do the padding in the
trainer and didn't bad when
pre-processing the data either
padding inside the trainer is normally
the default but only if you provide your
tokenizer to the trainer and we forget
to do that
so let's fix the issue and run again
this time we get a nasty good ir
those are very difficult to debug
because for one
you put your kernel in a state that is
not recoverable so you have to restart
your notebook from the beginning
and two the traceback is completely
useless for both
here the traceback tells us the error
happens when we do the gradient
computation we flustered backward but as
we'll see later on that is not the case
this is because everything that happens
on the gpu is done asynchronously when
you execute the model core
what the program does is just stacking
that in the queue of the gpu
then if the gpu didn't have any current
job to do the work will start on the gpu
at the same time as the cpu moves to the
next instruction
continuing with the extraction of the
loss this is stacked into the gpu queue
while the cpu moves to the instruction
lasted backward
but the gpu still hasn't finished the
forward pass of the model since all of
that took no time at all
the cpu stops moving forward because
lasted backward has an instruction
telling it to wait for the gpus to be
finished to make sure the gradients are
correct
when the gpu encounters an error it
gives it back to the cpu with a cryptic
message raises the error at the wrong
place
so to debug this we'll need to execute
the next steps of the training pipeline
on the cpu
it's very easy to do and we get a trace
back we can trust this time
as we said before the error actually
happens during the forward pass of the
model and not let's start backward
it's an index error
with a bit of debugging we see we have
labels ranging from 0 to 2 so 3
different values but our outputs have a
shape of batch size per 2.
looks like our model has the wrong
number of labels
we can indeed confirm that and now that
we know it's easy to fix it in the code
by adding normal labels equal 3 when we
create the model
now the training strip will run the
completion
we did not need it but here is how we
would debug the next step of the
pipeline quadrant computation
as well as the optimizer step
with all of this good luck debugging
your own trainings
you